Russian interference Russian
interference Russian interference in the
presidential election Russian
interference you have this letter from
Vlad yes
Russian hack to Russian interference in
the election intentionally interfere
with the election Russia's meddling in
the election collusion with the Russians
the FBI was looking into collusion with
the Russians this newest investigation
now in the hands of Special Counsel
Robert Robert Mueller Russia collusion
Bob Muller is expanding the
investigation total fabrication fidence
of collusion illusion between Russia the
Trump campaign new developments in the
Russia investigation the investigation
the Mahler investigation the Robert
Muller's investigations Russia collusion
in the 2016 election Russia
investigation Trump campaigns possible
collusion with Russia Donald Trump's
campaign and Russia there was no
collusion with Russia
there was no obstruction and none
whatsoever